welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka death Vader and
it's time to go back to a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away with the
release of the fifth episode of the
mandalorian the new release sees the man
doe and his best buddy baby Yoda
traveling to a familiar Star Wars
location and bumping into a couple of
brand-new characters throughout this
video we'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the latest
episodes overall plot the Easter eggs
and our theories on who the mysterious
stranger at the end could be this entry
is packed with tons of references to the
overall Star Wars universe and out of
all of the episode so far this
definitely feels like it's giving people
the most fanservice there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch episode 5 yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now make sure
you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this every day and
weekly coverage on the mandalorian and
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for click in this video
now let's get into a breakdown of the
Mandalorian episode 5 okay so episode 5
titled the gunslinger picks up right
after the events of episode 4 with mando
leaving saga in order to find safe
harbor in the galaxy last time the
character had hoped that he might have
found a safe place for baby Yoda to grow
old well grow old very slowly because
damn my man looks good for 50 however
all hopes of this happening were dashed
away by a bounty hunter that showed up
trying to kill the character as grief
kaga told the Mandalorian the baby has a
tracking fob in it and this means that
no matter where they go no matter where
they hide they will always have to look
over their shoulder this is exemplified
by the opening of episode 5 in which we
see mando ship the razor's crest being
chased through space by a bounty hunter
and really talked all that much about
the races crest in my breakdown videos
so far but it's actually a former
military craft that mono had repurposed
in order to carry out his missions the
razor's crest has a very similar design
to many of the clone troopers ships and
is said to have existed before the rise
of the Empire thus we can guess that it
was used in military campaigns during
the Clone Wars it's age shows itself to
as the Bounty Hunter that follow
the pair busts up one of the engines of
the craft Amano has to use special
tactics in order to take out the pursuer
I love how the bounty hunter named Ryu
ma has a sort of fighter pilot look to
him and this kind of reminded me a bit
of Top Gun and Independence Day with his
mask and helmet bearing a lot of
similarities to the ones that we would
see in our own world baby Yara can be
seen strapped in tight and this kind of
shows how he will be in the episode as
the character pretty much takes a
backseat to most of the proceedings
mando desperate to land goes to the
closest planet to him and he is hailed
in by none other than moss eisely tower
that's right we're visiting probably the
most famous planet in the Star Wars
universe
Tatooine home of the likes of the
Skywalker's obi-wan Kenobi Jabba the
Hutt and pit droids from the Phantom
Menace which we see waiting to greet him
upon his arrival mando a little paranoid
for obvious reasons shoots at them upon
exiting his ship and this draws the
attention of Pelham Otto the mechanic
that works at the bay who offers to fix
his ship as we've seen though mando has
found it more difficult getting a job
than Jesse Smollett sorry juice a small
eh and he spent the last couple of weeks
running from the Empire and bounty
hunters rather than working luckily he's
in the one place that has the galaxy's
biggest collection of scum and villainy
and he heads to the infamous Mos Eisley
cantina to look for work the lead up to
this is filled with hints that the
Empire is in welcome on the planet and
we also see the pit droids and Pelle
playing a game of sabacc
which is notorious in the Star Wars
universe baby Yoda also makes a force
cry I want to say force cry anyway it's
the same noise that ob1 used to scare
off the Tusken Raiders in a new hope and
this draws the attention of pally who's
probably over the moon that she's
actually managed to find the one thing
that her kids have been asking for this
Christmas watching the little guy walk
down the ramp is adorable and who
wouldn't instantly fall in love with the
character Darth Vader probably yeah
that's who curse your cold heart Vader
anyway in the lead-up to the canteen and
we pass the outside of it which is sure
exactly how it was in a new hope and we
also see where Luke and Han met for the
first time and where Greedo said the
infamous
Ashton Stone words McClung key every
week before doing a video I do wonder
how I'm gonna get him a clunky reference
in and they pretty much handed this one
on a play with one of the main
characters in the episode Toro sitting
in the exact same place that Han shot
first way or was it was a Greedo shot
first no no it was Han wait I don't even
know anymore Toro is played by the son
of Bobby Cannavale who you may recognize
from the Irishman and ant-man and he has
a job for the character it needs a hand
the target is Fennec Shand and knowing
her reputation as an elite mercenary man
Oh turns it down
this is Toros first job and he offers
man no the entire money for doing it as
long as he helps him due to the fact
that doing the job will get him into the
guild we all know man who loves to help
young men and it's great seeing him rub
shoulders with a new bounty hunter also
we see a droid working in the cantina
that could be the same one that worked
in Jabba's palace and a gonk droid
patrolling his ship I guess the most
Eisley cantina changed their position on
the no droid policy which just shows you
this show is so woke mando learns the
hard way that you don't leave baby odor
behind but luckily Pelle is on the case
Toro brings to soup bikes as their rides
and for those who don't know these were
introduced in shadows of the Empire
before being brought into the main Star
Wars law one looks extremely similar to
the one that Anakin rides in the attack
of the clones and he and Toro head out
the scene is incredible and whenever
they do these kind of shots in the
Mandalorian they always knock it out of
the park I love how there's a sort of
race between the two as it shows just
how much Toro wishes to impress and he
races ahead like a bull at one of them
Spanish things because because because
he's called Toro
as with most journeys into the
wilderness of Tatooine the pair come
across some Tusken Raiders and banter
similar to how they got Luke in a new
hope we see two just idling by whilst
the real threats sneak up on them it's
actually good to see Raiders not just
attacking for the sake of it for once
and hey maybe these guys just have a bad
rep after all maybe maybe Kathleen
Kennedy isn't a bad person eating I
can't say that the two then run into a
two back which is pulling a dead bounty
under behind it before you can even say
I have a bad feeling about this
mando spots the tracking fob and is shot
by fennec from afar with an MK modified
rifle man who decides to wait until
nightfall for the cover of darkness and
this is really like a cat-and-mouse
situation I don't know if you've ever
played Metal Gear Solid 3 but there was
a part in it in which you went face to
face with a sniper across like a huge
open world area and this gave me a lot
of flashbacks of that you could even set
the difficulty so that it was one shot
one kill and I loved situations that
have snipers in them as it's just so
tense and slow overall it makes for one
of the best action set-pieces that we've
had in the series so far the to race
across the area on sweet bikes using
flash transmitters or as we call them
players to blind the Scopes of fennec
and were able to see her up close and
personal and I realized that she's
played by my BAE Mei from agents of
shield
she's always excellent and yet she
certainly doesn't disappoint yet it
looks like mando is down by the
character but Toro sneaks up on her
buying time for mando to get in close
and capture the mercenary they take her
and alive after some persuasion from
mando they even call mando mando in this
episode which yeah I found that a bit
funny
now fennec does pay lip service to not
sing the Mandalorians for a long time
and also about Navarro which is revealed
to be the planet that the client and
griefer on Toro realizes that this
entire time he's been with one of the
most wanted people in the entire galaxy
and fennec says that if he lets a go
they can split the bounty Toro isn't
exactly into sharing anymore though and
he decides to shoot her instead stealing
the idea mando returns to pick them up
on his to you back and discovers their
body and then heads back to Mos Eisley
now personally I don't know if fennec is
actually dead and we do see feet later
on approaching her body I'll get into
that later at the end of the video but
yeah I just have a feeling that she'll
be back
back at the bay Toro has captured baby
Yoda and Pelle and he wants to take them
all into achieved legendary status
luckily for mando the kid is an absolute
idiot and it's not like we've seen him
get out of worse situations than this
before I love how Pelle says you're
smarter than you look
cuz to me just looks like Boba Fett who
who was an idiot let's face
it wasn't it yet he did nothing ie fell
into a pit and that was it
he pretty much mr. Magoo his way through
the entire store series don't at me and
mando kills taro easily but worst of all
it looks like baby Yoda may be hurt
luckily though he's okay and we remember
we must protect baby Yoda at all costs
Pelle takes Toros body to beggars Canyon
and man Oh heads up up and away the
episode ends on a sort of cliffhanger
with a stranger approaching Phoenix body
not only does this hint that the
character could be still alive to me
which I really hope she is because it's
a waste of talent to kill her off this
early but it also hints at what could be
happening down the line now this could
be a number of characters I'll just go
over the top three theories that I've
seen on the internet so we can see that
the character wears that cape so it
could either be grief cargo who is hot
on the tail of mando after his big
escape in Episode three and he does seem
like the kind of guy that would jangle
when he walks he could also be after
fennec if she has a high price on her
head however we rarely ever see grief
get his hands dirty and he seems more
like a handler rather than someone who
would go out on a job himself the other
theory that I've seen bounded about that
seems very unlikely is that it's the
client I'm not sure looks wise if he
quite fits this mold and similar to
grief he doesn't seem like the type of
character that would go out and do
things himself what seems most likely is
that it's in fact Giancarlo Esposito who
is rumored to be playing a character
known as moth Gideon we did see a shot
of him in the trailer
in similar surroundings to Tatooine and
from his costume he looks very closely
dressed to the minor glimpse that we got
fennec also in the episode appears to be
wearing an imperial uniform which could
show that she is or at least has been in
line with them off and this is why he
would be looking for her as it's likely
that fennec tried to escape the group
hence why she has a bounty on her head
now for those that don't know a moth is
a high-ranking Imperial governor and no
doubt the larger the legend of the
Mandalorian and the child becomes the
more that the higher-ups will be after
them I think this will definitely be the
most likely scenario and I can't wait to
see what happens in the future
especially if they're gonna go
head-to-head with
imperialist figures again this show is
breaking the bad curse of Star Wars
follow-ups and yeah I'm absolutely
loving it right now now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
Mandalorian Episode five as well as what
your theories for the future Oh make
sure you leave them in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed this
video then force push that like button
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of Korra tune which would be
linked at the end we go over everything
you need to know about the character and
give our theories on how she hints at
how the first order was created it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more and if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to joining we have
an awesome community so hopefully I see
you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 2 box on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel amour and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the mandalorian in the
comment section below but when it's
gonna be chosen on the 15th of December
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
you